ein neues projekt wird staaten minecraft
galaxy die erste folge wird am freitag
hochgeladen werden also übermorgen wenn
ich das video hat am mittwoch sieht und
es wird hammer geil das kann ich euch
jetzt schon mal sagen weil durch meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde heiden sieg auf dem
mailserver ich nehme jetzt einfach mal
changes interessante blogs instantly
latex schockiert plan was wir das
nochmal can change von unlimited als ja
ok neben den das heißt ich kann mich so
oft wie möglich verwandeln in
irgendeinen anderen blog das heißt wenn
ich zum beispiel sehr hey guck mal da
sind zäune und ich brauchen weder kann
werden ich wollte etwas verkünden und
zwar erst mal ich bin haider das ist
ganz super toll ich bin
solch ein schweinchen sein
am liebsten wäre ich echt irgendwie
sondern so ein blog den man nicht
vielleicht findet wie sda ich glaub ich
bin nach mir so ein stelle ich mich hin
und da jetzt bin ich so ein blog
ich wollte über etwas reden ich habe
einen shader drin ich hoffe da stört
euch nicht allzusehr sieht wunderschön
aus wenn die sonne aufgeht komme ich
nochmal so ach das ist die map wo wir ja
ja ja wo wir die heide abschließen
sollen können müssen tun weil sie nicht
mach das mal einfach nicht dass ich hier
ich hasse das ja eigentlich wenn ich ein
thema ansprechen will macht das gleiche
ich versuchen dinge zu töten
er ist selber tot
das ist einmal unglaublich ich schieße
ich die ganze zeit ab und nichts
passiert jetzt muss ich mir mal ganz
kurz irgendwie platz suchen
jetzt gehts hier anstrengen eben beinahe
täglich das auch irgendwo okay gut ich
bin schweine mit dem schwein so ich
wollte über etwas reden und zwar ein
neues projekt minecraft galaxy ich hatte
heute noch kein video weil morgen kommt
der leitindex wieder regelmäßig und
games ist halt kommen dran
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht okay ich
hab gerade heute keinen projekt party
machen kann deswegen minderheit entzieht
mal schauen wie es euch gefällt mal
wieder ist relativ dunkel die mit dem
scheitern muss man sagen eine runde
highland zieht einfach mal ich laufe
jetzt einfach um halt scheint mir so
langweilig eine runde wie komm ich
verstecke mich erst hab ich bin so
unentschlossen jeder ich bin jetzt
einfach mal einen tee blog stämmig
hierhin und jetzt schaue ich mir das
ganze an oder hin ist jemand ein neues
projekt wird starten minecraft galaxy
die erste folge wird am freitag
hochgeladen werden also übermorgen wenn
ihr das video hat am mittwoch sieht und
es wird hammer geil das kann ich euch
jetzt schon mal sagen es wird zwei teams
geben also es wird
ich möchte eigentlich dann die so viel
verraten ich weiß gar nicht wie viel ich
verraten darf
es wird auf jeden fall zwei fraktionen
geben zwei teams das werte ich als am
freitag sehen wir das auch noch mal
alles ganz genau erklären und die sind
halt nicht verfeindet aber sie sind halt
doch schon verfeindeter kommt sondern
halder anbauten millionen freunde und
ich möchte auch noch nicht sagen aber es
wird ein neues projekt kommentars
minecraft galaxy s wird auf jeden fall
da oben ist ein halter es wird richtig
richtig geil
und wir dürfen das hat heute schon
ankündigen ich glaub steht die hat sogar
schon sollen
ein video dazu gemacht ich wollte jetzt
einfach mal eins machen da ist auch
wieder ein haider einfach nur leute
freitag musst du dir auf jeden fall bei
mir vorbei gucken weil oder auch bei den
anderen leuten hier beißen das könnte
jetzt noch nicht wissen wie alles dabei
obwohl ich werds eine beschreibung
schreiben dann könnt ihr schon mal sehen
wer alles dabei ist ob wir den leuten
vorbei die werden alle am freitag die
erste folge hochladen
so gut wie alle weil einige waren durch
beim erst mal nicht dabei ich weiß nicht
genau wie das gehandhabt wird und es
wird wieder was richtig geiles und es
wird anders als light in the woods das
kann ich jetzt schon sagen
und sonst würde ich sagen wir spielen
doch eben diese runde hier zu ende und
dann hab ich videos für heute ihr habt
heute meine visage gesehen ich habe
übrigens beim mikrofon mal so ein
bisschen umgestellt ich wurde von
irgendwo abgeschossen weil einige
meinten ja das sollte man so ein gewese
blechern als man bis mit
auseinandergesetzt
ich hoffe dass es besser jetzt ich werde
mir wahrscheinlich eh bald wenn ich
umziehe nach hamburg
höchstwahrscheinlich wo bin ich denn
hier richtig stark richtig starker ich
das gemacht da läuft einfach mal in den
guten ton läuft einmal in den brunnen
gefragt wieso warum sie so viele leute
denken heute nicht ändern
hallo es geht
ich wollte auch mal ganz kurz euch noch
fragen wenn ich das jetzt mal ganz so
sehe
welches touchpad findet ihr denn cool
way back also ich hatte gerade die ganze
zeit mit julie graf gespielt das ist
jetzt das world pack ich würd's halt
wenn schon dann mit shader spielen was
ist da denn dass ich so eine höhle ich
nicht ganz so cool wie oli kraft aber
ist halt ein bisschen heller ein
bisschen sneaker gehalten so nach dem
motto nahm oder halt
moment ich werde gut geschlafen moment
ob sich denn hier an greift nicht die
schweine an oder momenten die sind nicht
die schweine die bewegen sich ganze
schweine dahinter mit einer ganz anteil
hoch geschossen oder zwecks ich finde
alle drei cool zwecks und juli kraft für
ihre coolsten tot
könnt ihr mir sagen was sie cool findet
dann werde ich damit in zukunft dann
immer spielen weil ich finde dass du auf
jeden fall sehr angenehmen läuft auch
flüssig beim aufnehmen und haydn sieges
super modus gibt es auch auf my next
jetzt die sich fragen
als nächstes steht in der beschreibung
nicht irgendwie hier nochmal sondern
crazy ding hochschießen oder super toll
weil wir nach 30 sekunden und ist nur
noch zwei haiders da hoffe ich schon
auch noch irgendwann wenn ich mich so
als kopf verwandeln könnte das wäre cool
nützt auch nichts mehr kommt das wäre es
wenn ich jetzt noch so wenn die beiden
jetzt noch zu erhalten
ich finds echt cool auch mit dem shader
und das ist egal welches tech speck ich
nehme sie echt cool aus also das hier
ist sie zeigt zugleich normal weil ich
jetzt wird ja jetzt sofort zurückgebaut
dass es wächst so sieht das auch relativ
hell und goalie kraft auch mal nicht so
doof juli greift da habt ihr jetzt halt
die auswahl was ihr sagt was besser ist
hier ja ich finde kraft jetzt eigentlich
bisschen cooler aber müsst ihr dürft das
entscheiden weil ihr guckt die videos
ich mache ja nur und von der lasse ich
die entscheidung der komplett bei euch
ich kann auch mal eben mit ihr das mal
so sieht kraft auch schön aber mit
shader ehrlich gesagt wenn ich finde
schöner wenn das so
solche teile sind weil sie nicht egal
ihr dürft das alles entscheiden juli
croft oder swex freitag startet das neue
projekt micro galaxy könnte bei mir auf
dem kanal vorbeigucken ich weiß nicht
genau ich glaub 18.30 wollten wir zu
klein oder 18 uhr im mai dauernden dreh
solltet ihr auf jeden fall online sein
und wird ganz cool ich will noch nicht
mehr verraten nur dass ein neues projekt
altstadt findet ihr seht alle teilnehmer
und in der beschreibung und dann